[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to the lobby
GameSpot's weekly would hang out here in
San Francisco California at 11 a.m.
every Wednesday I'm your host Mike
McCarty so glad you can join us here on
YouTube twitch GameSpot here's always
with Peter Brown reviews editor as
always sonic is good again sonic is
great again
apparently I've never beaten in Sonic he
would never played more than like two
levels so maybe this is my chance you've
been playing on the switch yeah just a
little bit and it's as good as Matt
Espinel he says in his review dope yeah
that's up on GameSpot we'll talk more
about that will talk more about Sonic
Rob Henry you you were up late last
night playing a game that has caught a
few of us out of nowhere
yeah observer and I'll say now I'm a
little little brain-dead I was up pretty
late playing observer games real cool I
can't wait to talk about it yeah we'll
get to that as always if you're joining
us we're in the chat on YouTube twitch
and GameSpot and as always Shh wait I
was so busy talking to you guys I didn't
realize
where's Kay oh my god is she in the
bathroom I haven't seen her today
actually now that I think about it we
don't have a fourth co-host we need
shouldn't you be on the TriCaster who's
doing TriCaster oh [ __ ] wasn't surprised
many of you who watched the lobby weekly
will know John Luke eezol he's usually
on our TriCaster back there he's the
voice of God
switching stuff in the back room we got
Eric hey on the TriCaster day and
Richard Lee produced and stuff from
behind the scenes so we figured why not
bring John Luke on cuz Callie's out of
town she is doing some preview coverage
where you guys pre-planned this joke
yeah I think the hidden wall was enough
of a surprise I don't think anybody
knows that there anyway yeah yeah see
people don't think those there but
anyway you don't leave good to have you
I know you're a big Sonic fan oh yeah
Sonic
you put up a history of Sonic video
recently that you worked on did a lot of
research on the series we're gonna get
through a lot today there's nidhogg -
there's agents of mayhem I know you're
loving that Rob mater fall son what is
what is what's XCOM
oh god
if you got a huge mansion or the chosen
we're gonna talk about ex-cons were the
chosen expansion yeah we got like five
minutes in the show before I mention it
but anyway we're so glad I could join us
as always we have a giveaway later on
the show I'll tell you all about that
later on Shiva's gonna put it in the
twitch chat and then we're just gonna
tweet it from GameSpot's account so go
follow a GameSpot in the meantime on
Twitter if you have not already cool few
news items we talked a little bit about
law breakers over the last couple
episodes but we have our official review
up on GameSpot Miguel concepción wrote
it and YouTube and YouTube you can go
watch them both spot you a read of mine
GameSpot I read on GameSpot we it's a
good game we all liked a steep learning
curve from what I gather we do we did
have a few more problems on ps4 then we
do with PC the tutorial yeah there's
like not tutorials on the ps4 version
that are present on PC is you can also
get money from and you get like rewards
from it yeah so I guess ps4 version is
not a most ideal place although I played
a little bit of ps4 you know like the
controls just wouldn't yeah this games
very much yeah we talked a couple times
about how it very much feels like a PC
shooter I like it I think it cool it
blends those the hero shooter elements
of like overwatch or you know the
lesser-known battleborn but it also kind
of brings in that quake Unreal
Tournament kind of feel so yeah our full
reviews up on GameSpot you can also
watch it on GameSpot or YouTube so go
check that out I heard it's not doing
very well yeah I think like day after
launch only had three thousand players
peek yeah and then like later I was like
that across all platforms interesting
yeah I wonder I mean it was kind of
under everyone's radar for a while and
then we started playing the Alpha the
beta and then before we knew it we like
holy [ __ ] there's coming out and what
August 8th it's here but which is kind
of the case with a lot of games this
year but that's kind of a bummer to hear
because I enjoyed my time in this game
it's fun it reminds me of when like
tribe's was rebooted a couple years ago
right yeah and like people were kind of
excited for that because it was like
yeah it's a return to like PC like weird
mobility shooters but it didn't really
catch fire and I wonder yeah just not
enough marketing maybe that's what I
something like that mean it was changed
like who was uh published or know who
was doing marketing Nexon or whatever
yeah yeah I don't know it's I wonder how
it makes me think of I wonder how quake
champion is gonna do right I wonder that
I mean I mean Bethesda is always really
prevailing sentiment I've seen from
people is that they're like oh the game
play is really fun but I don't
necessarily like the world or the
character yeah and I got that 90s very
like like oh good kill you know
comparing it to like well I think it's
very different game from overwatch like
overwatch does have this beat in terms
of like they're fun characters that are
like inviting and you want to play yes
you know like May or something like I
don't care about the characters in this
game at all I care about them as a video
game like characters with mechanics sure
yes yeah from what I played there's a
couple of classes once it it's tough to
find your role in this game but once I
did I had more fun with it but I don't
know if I'll go back to it everything
else that's going on unfortunately maybe
that's just kind of a prevailing
sentiment across the board but either
way we can go for it that game yeah yeah
overwatch last week this is kind of a
little outdated but still worth
mentioning cuz I always bring up over
watched news team deathmatch was on PTR
last week across or sorry on a PC so now
you can actually finally people have a
chance to play just without the actual
objectives just killing each other so
I'm interested to see how the character
meta kind of shapes up in that mode
specifically you see Ben GenCon Eric Tay
if you're watching this live there
that's their livestream right there both
seasoned overwatch players as someone
who has not played over a watch I was
kind of shocked when this was announced
cuz it was like wait there isn't team
deathmatch
yeah already it's always been like
escorting a payload or this like Street
Fighter in my opinion it's like Street
Fighter 5 shipping without a proper vs.
mode it's kind of funny to think too
that overwatch I'm sorry overwatch blah
breakers doesn't have a deathmatch mode
I think law breakers is more surprising
cuz that yeah at least all the
characters are the game is designed
where all the characters are balanced to
be able to kill each other
yeah offensive overwatch it's like you
know you can kill someone as like a
mercy but you're not
then to her you know that's not the
point of that character so this I at
least understand why that kind of held
off on that because yeah I think they
want people to think of it more as a
yeah
you know it's just my problem having not
I mean I played I played a lot of war
watch and then when they announced it's
like oh [ __ ] they don't have team
bathmats that's right it is weird cuz uh
but usually because you said a lot of us
characters like a couple my mains are
not meant for killing sorry I can't kill
people on I can kill people but you know
it's not their go-to mo well so how's it
feel you guys had any time to play
deathmatch I haven't no yeah cuz I mean
this game is always something I'll go
back to and I'm interested to see it
more I don't do we know if it's still on
PTR I believe it's off now I could be
wrong but I will have to check that out
hey my nose hey what now he's on the
voice of God right now but uh yeah you
can go watch this live stream if you
want to check out more of it if you
haven't played again you're sitting
going to play it and then yesterday
undertale came to ps4 and Vita I think
this is when I'm finally gonna play it
I've been wanting to for like two years
it's not that long
I know Jake Decker just started out his
Vita like I'm this morning's commute or
last night maybe but why he had at his
desk yeah yeah what Vita yeah um I
really want play this we talked more
about it out Kali's a huge fan of it she
again she thought nothing like a preview
event this week and I think next week a
little bit too but she was saying that
she's definitely gonna replay it and
it's one of those games that I mean we
had a freelancer I think we had a
freelancer yeah who did the review but
like it was sent in you're like this
pretty much it really like scam and a
bunch of people around here played it
and everybody really fell in love with
it yeah it's a it's a very quirky very
surprising and funny experience and it's
and it's not too difficult you know I've
recommend it to anybody who likes video
games to backtrack briefly GUP shoe riot
unofficial official number one GameSpot
fans said the team deathmatch and
overwatch is still in PTR didn't go live
yet officially but yes okay and this was
handled by my friends at eight four
productions Mark Richt here sorry John
Ricky arty mark is no longer with them
he's at enhance games down but
localization company he does stuff like
fire in blown
Michael stuff one of the reasons I love
persona 5 so much like one of the many
reasons is that it's really good about
kind of playing with the RPG tropes and
I know undertale that's a huge draw of
that it is like a primary component okay
yeah cool have you guys you I don't
think you've played on her tail no but
we talked about it before and yeah yeah
yeah this is time to come back to it
definitely
assuming you have oh yeah I love
undertale I bought the collector's
edition although I think it doesn't get
shipped for another month or something
like okay which kind of sucks but
interesting it's fine cool that's all
the news I had laid out again we have a
giveaway I don't notice that later on
the show will have Sheva tweeted from
our account but let's get into what's
new this week nidhogg to yes is out our
review is up oscar deus over in the UK
reviewed it he likes it
I saw you would Justin playing in the
office yeah we really like it too I
think there's some things it does that
are new that are good and some that
maybe aren't for the better yeah it's it
I mean for context people who don't know
the first game very minimalistic kind of
you know like what you would see is an
indie game but it's to character
sparring across several stages on one
level look at several levels on one
stage but it's like it's like a simple
fencing sprinting game and you have
little things you can do like you know
you tack low medium or high you can
throw your sword and you can use the
position of your sword how you through
it's like deflect incoming attacks yeah
so simple on the surface but a lot of
depth and ways to strategize and that's
still the same case here the visuals
have changed quite a bit
it's yet they're very divisive I love
them I like it's the tone very well I
think yeah if I were to look at this
right now non to a game I'd be like it's
just the character models for me like
the backgrounds I love just something
about the I love the run supposed to be
needs I don't know but you can customize
them quite a bit now so you can change
equipment on their feet I think their
ankles and they're like almost every
segment of their body can be changed
customized which is nice so they don't
always have to wear chastity belts like
these three right but I mean you like
the visuals like sometimes this there's
a level where you end up like in the
belly of a beast and it's just like all
these like you surrounded by just
discussing things but it works but so
what you're seeing now is dagger and
arrow being used several weapons now
right this is the thing that bothers me
it's not so basically what the game does
is you die frequently and you respawn
and whoever did the last kill is the one
who gets to run to the other side of the
screen and progress so when you come
back and original nidhogg you just have
the same weapon you always had and in
hog - you may not come back with a
standard rapier you might come back with
a broadsword or with a bone arrow or
with a dagger and they all have
different properties and require
different tactics to use properly the
problem is I don't think there's a set
order with which they appear after you
die and you can't disable this option
regardless if you're playing offline or
online or against the CPU and someone
like myself who really enjoys the purity
of just using like a single weapon and
the balance right and the balance as
well I mean I think there's there's room
to explore all these weapons and I not
gonna say that they're in balance but
there was something very simple to
understand about just a one weapon and
so maybe it requires a little bit more
play time but I know that like when my
reach goes from what you're seeing here
to like a little stabby dagger or my
speed changes because I have to load my
bow before I can fire it it feels very
different and it puts me in a
disadvantage
I'm okay with it being in the game but
it it absolutely needs an option to be
disabled yeah and it's one of those
scenarios where I don't I can't believe
that like feedback wasn't given if they
gave this to like outside people to test
yeah or maybe the devs we're just so
steadfast and in their their plan I
don't know but give players options yeah
give them options especially when it
comes to something like this yeah cuz I
because watching it it seems like it
could lead to some hilarious hijinks
just not knowing what weapon you're
gonna spawn with as you said it can be
fun but I definitely in the long run if
I was gonna try to get better at this
game and someone was actually like
playing me like I see gadge here at
GameSpot's in our twitch chat and he's
one of the best Smash Bros players I've
ever seen like I mean it kind of reminds
me of like trying to get good at
something and of course there's that
randomize RNG element of it everybody
could make it his character and smash
right it was like okay I guess I'll
figure out how to play this character
yeah you kind of notice every time
anybody gets the broadsword here it's
just one vertical slash that covers like
the entire character mama know so there
are also like nuanced little things you
can do like you can roll underneath the
character you
and even from a roll do a little hop but
you can like use a specific weapon to
change the properties of that hop it's
it's kind of neat what it opens up but
again
yeah the the randomness or at least the
seemingly randomness of it all is in my
opinion the perhaps the only fault this
game has he may be
he or she may be just trolling but rad
skull and the twitch chat says is this a
ripoff of nidhogg right here if you're
watching this you could see the that's
snowman centipede it reminds me of the
Calgary Hobbes snow creatures these
grotesque things I really do like the
art style or at least the tone they're
going for it's great and there's like a
dozen levels I think I've only played
maybe about half of them and each level
will have you know it's got maybe I
think you can see here like seven or
eight screens based on those squares up
top and each of those screens like
carries a little bit of a variation on
the overall theme so at the very least I
mean yeah it's a good game at the very
least it's a great always a great like
party game yeah if you ask me it's a
great game I mean the moment we started
playing it it was it was a lot of fun oh
yeah I was well I was just enjoying
watching you it's definitely a person
like it's it's fun just to watch and
laugh at someone just like eat it after
a kill or talking [ __ ] or something I
was just an int a play a match for over
20 minutes Wow
so that's the ultimate goal as this
screen would suggest getting eaten by
that dude yes which I think might be the
new tog yep okay Norris I was gonna say
it's gotta be something like an actual
mythical creature like I guess what's
that chicken doing get out of it's like
a cockfighting ring
how are the stages because I in the
first one I always felt like I went back
to the the castle stage like I thought
that was like the purest stage to play
on so I've only played a few of them I
mean it's certainly like the visuals
disrupt some of the clear like layouts
of levels a little bit but I didn't find
myself ever thinking like oh this level
sucks or that level sucks at least in my
experience it's so much about that
one-to-one engagement of the fight that
the stage for me was secondary well for
me like the I didn't think any of those
stages sucked and the first one was more
that they would introduce sort of like
outside traps are like pitfalls they're
like oh well we seem to keep falling in
this pit so let's just pick that stage
because it doesn't have any
that kind of like how people do like you
know what a final destination in smash
yeah right hearest I got you yeah I
guess I haven't played enough yet to
really form a strong opinion about that
unfortunately Eric Green in the YouTube
chat jean-luc was saying yeah and it
hogs the worm that devours the world
trees roots yes well in this case
grotesque Simpson characters as people
are calling this this level what's
frustrating but in a funny way these
doors opening and closing and stopping
arrows and stopping your face one of my
favorite activity or not strategies is
to just stop like when I get control and
wait for the person to come to me like
those stalemate standoffs are really
tense that's the most like disturbingly
benign way to say that my favorite
activity is holding my rapier out for
someone to run into it and just inhale
their sternum on even having like these
new weapons just like in the level right
or like at certain stages so you can
predict
oh I kick kick I love the revamp kick
there's like a dive kick looking kind of
that wasn't that was in the first game
as well but the the kick the standing
kick you do now I don't think it was
infinite now you can just span it and
like literally kick your way across the
screen alright you were doing that
that's frustrating I kick him I could
watch this game two people play this
game for hours but anyway yeah our
review is up on GameSpot do we have a
video component to that no don't think
so she's a written review Oscar Davis in
the UK a really good review you can go
check that out for more in-depth take on
the game I do actually have a question
quick from Twitter of Tay has it queued
up it's someone's s about the soundtrack
cuz they really like the soundtrack said
is Daedalus doing knit hogs
OST and I looked into it and they are
involved with a couple transom yeah yeah
and then but along with dose one muck
Smule and Osbourne or some of the other
artists and that was from cosmic Nomad
on Twitter Eric V thank you for your
question and he also asked well nidhogg
to have more than four stages did they
update the first game at all or did it
just was it the same I don't remember
yeah there are very there's like three
time so who knows we don't know for sure
but maybe they will add some new maps in
the future as of now there are four
wouldn't it hug too as well is it is
this oh no there's like twelve inna talk
to you oh really Oh
okay cool well then the answer is yes
we'll talk to it more than four stages
Eric V yeah you betcha
yeah is this coming to the switch
because this seems like perfect right
like the two joy cons there was news
about them commenting on it yesterday I
thought I don't think there's plans yet
but it would make sense to have it on it
right yeah yeah it'd be maybe great
every dance I know I heard blood-borne
is gonna come this way oh cool yeah good
you didn't you're a liar no I didn't run
20 frames a second almost speaking of no
good segue
you've been playing agents of mayhem
which is not on the switch the framerate
seemed okay from what I saw
the framerate was okay just the frame
constantly shakes well at that one
instance where do you want to begin we
were the most negative review on the
internet I think okay let me let me
let's this is purely our experience for
her calm down quick and I grant it
wasn't we did not really didn't actually
write the review and our reviewer
alignment but I agree with it yeah sorry
I didn't mean to get us fired up right
away um Robin playing agents of mayhem
from the developers of like Saints Row
three and four listen volition they made
what looks kind of like st. arrow mixed
with crack down a little bit
can you explain the premise I mean to me
Robert we have a few questions for the
game we'll get to later but set the
stage for people who don't know the
premise is that you are on the agents of
mayhem and you are trying to save the
city of Seoul in Korea and you're like
evil men hell-bent on overtaking they're
like there's some acronym like that they
are trying to just blow up stuff yeah
sure and I mean the point you have like
a lineup of agents and you unlock them
as you progress and you get to pick
three and customize your squad and they
all have these you know the very
distinct abilities like you know you're
Archer your weapons expert with a
shotgun and you get to switch them on
the fly and cruise and open world and
get in cars and wreak havoc you know
it's like very much as a Saints like
it's got that Saints Row feel but I I
feel like
this in general is like kind of dated
like ionically you brought it up and I
kind of like agree with like we're
saint's row game like I kind of remember
him differently after playing this like
if I eat I think I'd only only played
three the third but like a dildo gun I
think we're the dildo bat or whatever so
I know people like these games but then
I like like the humor of this one
specifically is actually where I'm kind
of getting I you know you think of GTA
right which is like very grounded for
the most part but here it's just like
unless you're in a plane yeah sure
you're just but here you're just like
you know it's very trophy like just
really bad in like juvenile writing with
like Dom's swear words just thrown in
like so aggressively that I just don't
I've never laughed at any of these like
they're making Uranus jokes I did feels
like like not even a 12 year old would
would laugh at this yeah like this made
me kind of question if like what saints
row funny right you know and then I went
back and I'm not gonna say those games
were like you know they hit the nail on
the head every time but there was always
more of like an absurdist quality to
them and embraced it for sure yeah they
embraced it that it never felt like the
they are least different characters and
in it but they never felt like they were
using minorities as like the butt of a
joke in that game you know it was
actually like weirdly respectful of kind
of like its characters and its ideas and
was kind of more making fun of the
bizarre situations they were in this
like from what you've was watching like
just like the characters and they all
feel one note one note for
one-dimensional like I'm an Asian guy
the dragon I'm I'm a Mexican like it's
just not appealing and I feels just like
weirdly dated but not even appropriate I
don't know it's so what you saw there
also was like your ultimate ability
which every character has you know going
on it's it's a trend now it is right
like turn on your old that guy just puts
on shades this is Hollywood by the way
so he's here he's your real you know
fooled himself character who was always
pushing buttons and
making people like annoyed with how old
himself he is doesn't play by the rules
he no no never
he puts on his shades and his that's his
ultimate and all that happens is
explosions just appear and blow up
things so it's sound like where's your
suppose the skill involved you like you
know what I mean like like let's take a
wider view though because it's like the
challenges that you're actually involved
in are pretty benign as well right yeah
the idea that you'd even need these to
begin with is like not that compelling
sure and and by OneNote also like not
just their characters like their weapons
like this he just he is his primary
assault rifle and then this grenade that
you that's on a cool down that he
thrusts with his pelvis mm-hmm in a very
funny funny way solid earlier I just
doing a crotch chop and that but that's
about it for most of these characters I
mean it's just man if you couldn't like
swap on the fly I think the gameplay
would be even more boring I remember
crackdown 2 I like the first crackdown
and that you know remains to be seen
what they're gonna do with the third one
but the second crackdown when they added
that in it kind of what you touched on
Pete every time I went to do something
it was always the same kind of banal
because clear out this zombie
infestation clear out this gang
infestation I didn't have the variety
that I liked in the first game at least
when it was kind of like coming in on
the early end of the Xbox 360 but yeah
that's from watching you play rob that's
what it seems with agents of mayhem it
seems like you know open worlds just
kind of raise the bar this year in a few
different situations from a few
different developers this doesn't look
like they have updated stuff well that
brings up a good point of like another
gripe that our reviewer also had which
was like you know you engage so you have
like a home base called Ark which is
like this is like Helicarrier that
floats in the sky so you go back there
to you know do a variety of things like
upgrade all your abilities get your
missions mainly so you get you know your
main missions to like find other agents
and bring them aboard so there's one
we're like you you start the mission on
your health care it's called the Ark as
your base you hit a loading screen you
warp back out into the open world and
then you go from A to B and you get
there and more often than not it's just
a needless like Waypoint where you
arrive and a lot of
it's someone on you know your like your
operator so to speak it's just like you
arrive at this destination and here she
says Oh bad Intel
and it's just a bunch of guys who you
shoot and he was go over here now so
then it's a three minute drive to to
this other Waypoint and he arrived there
and then the mission that I was supposed
to start finally starts after like six
minutes it feels like it and that is in
itself repetitive as heck we're like you
or or you're if you're not doing that
you're climbing a building for no reason
to get to the top only to like meet
someone but but it's never like
justified right like I'm just why my on
top of building now oh now I gotta go
down there Mondays I saw you killed
quite a few civilians when you call your
car and it works out of nowhere and it's
kind of odd yeah it's really funny but I
don't know if it fits totally been
jenkees on our YouTube chat he says that
it essentially is a continuation the
same for a story cuz at least three the
characters are returning I don't know
which one I wouldn't know that Laura
well enough yeah what about the
technical issues cuz the only time I
watched you play this screen was
literally shaking up and down and I
think that was a kind of regular across
reviews that are a lot of other people
noticing that me a lot of different
that's like a few of our questions there
like a lot of different tire tears than
the one now showing and the thing was I
was this is this was like I've seen this
so many times I was trying to explain to
you that like the AI in the streets like
you you know if you think about it even
like GTA which again you know that's a
really hard bar so you know it's
understandable that it's hard matched
that level of AI but in that game GTA
you you cause an explosion and you know
the pedestrians and and the AI like
freak out you know eventually but here
you just walk into it you walk into like
an intersection and this is not there
already I was trying to explain Peter
this and then I was like what's going
are you doing this was like no this is
me putting the controller down on the
desk looks like a the game the game was
doing all this by listening it looks
like he's just pressing the left game
but I'm not I'm stopping in the gaming
I'm not doing in here's like the robot
just like glitching out yeah the robot
does a few bad things and that's not
cars just like inexplicably like that's
was a linear right lane and then being
like I'm gonna cross
traffic for no reason just kidding
accidents and that spot that's by like
you again like you this is the a
operating by itself this is ps4 is ps4
and so imagine when I set off an
explosion or like block and intersection
then it's just like a I and so stiff and
it's just like they rock it up in a car
or like a car like randomly just like
rolls it's like nothing seems look like
I don't know like well put together like
the AI itself like there are so like
like few AI like white like pedestrians
walking on the world world like you will
turn a corner and there's like no this
is a huge city and there's like one
person in the street well there's two
people I was showing you this he was
Joey was showing footage of like AI like
having a conversation there dialogue is
obviously enter my are monologues but
they're talking to each other like this
so ones facing this way ones facing like
this way and then like his hand is going
through this guy's head and that's just
like time and time again like time and
time after again you just like see these
like bugs and those are in my opinion
game breaking if framerate this is this
like yeah chugs yeah I like a 20 you
like if I say you don't like the game
yeah you've been you've been talking
smack about it a lot too so it's kind of
site about it yeah it looks like dumb
fun which we can all use this year it
has to be done right yeah why do you
think about saints row yes each row I
probably has some of that stuff too or
you know like the AI is not the best in
the city and stuff like that but the
game is constantly having you just do
like fun interesting stuff like you know
now you're jumping out of a helicopter
into a pool and you know killing
everyone I are going into a virtual
reality world now you're stealing this
VTOL and doing this like they're they're
just constantly throwing new things
about you and are at you and wrapping
around characters that I I felt were
like actually like pretty interesting
and like compelling characters for the
most part and it feels like this game
just like has none of that yeah I mean
that's that's the thing to rag there's
no like redeeming quality
like if it was the character so it was
like good writing but again like a
Uranus joke mm-hmm was it 1990 like
someone just like actually it's
pronounced Uranus it's like and this is
while I'm like climbing a building and
getting stuck in a wall or like my feet
don't match Italy clamped the top of
buildings and the geometry doesn't line
up so you're like 5 feet above on like
top of a building like almost always it
feels like kind of a good segue into
this question from forsaken alpha on
Twitter they asked his agents of mayhem
fun after all the performance issues
doesn't sound it doesn't sound like the
design kind of supports much in this
game yeah I'm running out of things to
talk about and it's just it maybe it
says something about the game yeah I I
would not recommend that run the scan
not recommend it this game got one more
question
a few people were asking about its lack
of co-op would people expect co-op in
this kind of game I mean again crackdown
had it in the first game I believe right
no the first crackdown didn't they have
it you could play online it could be
mistaken I want that up but so I'm
Muhammad s point o said do you think
agents of mayhem would have performed
better had a not been single-player only
with the technical issues I feel like
would have made it worse
I mean I don't think since ro ever had
co-op yeah that's what a few people
asked them well when I first saw this
game when they first announced it I
immediately thought it was co-op because
they were showing like here's all these
different characters each with wacky
abilities you know they have alts and
they you know this one's like stealth
and this one you know just like ranged I
was like oh okay this is gonna be like a
co-op game you know you're picking
different characters and classes and
your mix and matching so for it to be
this weird like no it's just you by
yourself and you're just hot swapping
between them that's not necessarily a
bad idea but that's yeah like I totally
expected it to be cooperative then part
of the idea just to clarify before we
talk more about a co-op is a multiplayer
game mode in Saints Row one two three
four and get out of hell
turn crackdown okay yeah so that's so
maybe that's why people were expecting
it because same developer like why not
maybe but after seeing the technical
issues with a single player at least on
our ps4
experience who knows that it would have
even worked if two people are playing
yeah what I was gonna say that was like
the characters like they make sense in
this and when you're at your home base
and you're looking at your next mission
it's like kind of gives you some
description like oh this is a little
more like a stealthy operation so then
you customize and pick your agents for
that right which makes sense again but
so our review is up for that on GameSpot
you go check that out more in-depth we
have a video review that review for that
we do we do female watched it on YouTube
and was see more of the performance
issues if you want to check those out
don't know why you would but I do like
the game yeah maybe we'll have fun with
it like I said it it seemed to me like
they were going for dumb fun that
doesn't mean they did it right but you
can go see for yourself you want to
check it out and our video reviews and
our review on site I don't know how much
will be we'll have to talk about matter
fall from housemarque they just recently
released next machina you might also
know them from resogun fame yes and
Super Stardust and Super Stardust it
matter fall came out 2d action
platformer released does that release
today came out 15 yesterday yesterday
okay
cuz I see my name going down the
leaderboards which means more people
okay that's your excuse what the hell
but you played a little bit matter fall
we had a nice to review this oh we did
yes and the game got a 6 you know which
I prefer to refer to it as the word that
represents which is a fair game for me
personally it's somewhere between a fair
and a good game because it it has so
much of what housemarque does well in it
although the problem is is that it's not
necessarily combined in a way that that
makes you sort of have that moment of
like oh wow this is this is rad like the
way that I got the first time I played
resogun the way that I got the first
time I played next machina and those
games were sort of derived off of
defender and like Smash TV specifically
but I felt like it brought those up in a
really interesting way it's hard to
really pinpoint if anything what matter
fall is mimicking mm-hmm but that's not
necessarily important it doesn't have to
be you know Maj or you know a remake
idea but it feels I don't know it feels
like there's something missing and first
of all it's a little short it's only 12
stages which includes boss battles which
are their own stage so it's really nine
stages and three bosses but as you sort
of go throughout the stages like you you
find yourself in rooms with a bunch of
enemies and it's like okay there's a lot
of enemies here and I have multiple ways
to take them out but it never quite
feels like a clever orchestration of
enemies that's one thing the biggest
problem though is the the - ability so
dashing is something that housemarque
uses in pretty much all of their games
and it's a very important way of not
only getting out of danger but sometimes
inflicting damage or about good or
debuff on your enemy and in most of
their games as far as I can recall it's
very easy to know when you can - and
when you can't because it's usually on a
cooldown timer and there's some sort of
visual or audible indicator there is
nothing like that here and so these
stages that you're watching me play
they're not that difficult but there are
some especially once you get outside of
the first main area the first batch of
levels where you need to be able to
scape at a moment's notice but even if
you're not in that moment to moment
thing and you just want to be able to
use your - freely you don't know if you
can and this this thing that's supposed
to be your reliable get-out-of-jail-free
card you can't really rely on it and
that's a real misstep because you
basically feel like well I have all
these tools at my disposal but the most
important one I can't count on it every
time I need to and and that's a real
problem that that that definitely hurts
the experience of playing this game yeah
my initial reaction when I first saw
gameplay was oh that's awesome house
mark is doing a Metroidvania kind of
game it looked like maybe because it
just looked like Shadow Complex or just
because I'm ignorant it looked like a 2d
yep no it's a yeah it's we have I mean
you could kind of look at it that way
like this so you the game is linear but
there are sort of like short alternate
paths you can find I'm an alternate just
like diversions and there you might find
citizens and these citizens might give
you health or an augment and these
augments are things like a grenade or a
buff for like your - ability or other
stuff and you can replay levels with
these things
because you're chasing high scores right
that's what the housemarque games are
all about so it's like Mega Man in the
sense that you get new abilities you can
customize yourself with but you're not
really getting them from bosses and like
you know yeah there's not like a key
weapon to take out a certain boss so
maybe your strategy will change
depending on how you get these augments
and you'll go back but you're playing
the same levels over again and again the
levels themselves aren't that
interesting there's nothing I can't
remember a single level I was like this
moment was cool housemarque off he's
always been awesome about replayability
like you don't beat their game
especially when resogun was on the ps4
launch lineup I next machina same thing
I just wanted to keep playing that just
purely records difficulty phonetic
energy yeah and it's difficulty and you
start getting better at you get the
muscle memory to twitch reactions and
that's all fine here it just it it
doesn't I felt this game less surprising
that I hoped it would be an easy easier
to walk away from that I expected damn
well you can go look more to this I mean
do you guys have any questions about it
how's the music Luke music's great I had
a music was really yeah I don't know
music that's one of those things that
really drives the action right you know
so I mean with like comparable to like
next machina mmhmm yeah hey Ben
great that's look I'll be sure to listen
to it on Spotify yes yeah I've seen one
Spotify what guys think we are yeah you
can go read that review as well Jeremy
Winslow's one of our freelancers wrote
that like Pete said he gave us six out
of ten which means it's fair it is fair
that's a very fair assessment of a fair
game yes you know check that out on
GameSpot all right today I'm gonna
switch things up on you sorry oh because
it seems like we have more to talk about
with observer than I thought when I made
this run of show so I need to ask you
guys for some help I don't want to just
be talking this whole segment so I need
you guys to ask me question about XCOM
tubes where that shows an expansion
which i've spent like all week playing
and by all week I mean I think it's like
60 hours all right so I'll pretend to be
like someone who knows XCOM yeah but but
I'm not gonna ask you questions but I
want you to do is the things that you
want to talk about I want you to say you
know that thing like something they've
improved oh yeah it was different and
then you'll tell me what's different
what's so good why
so should I talk with her like insider
baseball XCOM terms for people who would
actually be watching this video yeah cuz
I I don't care about ex-cops or anyone
like me interests things might not
matter okay so I want it I want to know
as an expert like a fellow expert okay
what do you want to know you said you'd
ask a question so what's new man like
was a lot of new things so it's not just
DLC it's like enemy within
XCOM 2012 is XCOM enemy Unknown its
expansion that released a couple years
after actually revamped how a few the
systems work chief chief among them you
see the assassin here that's one of the
chosen there's three persistent bosses
that you'll fight throughout levels and
if you had played the alien hunters DLC
I love that it's different than that
because those you start chipping away at
their health and then they escape and
next time they come back they are still
at the healthy left the mat so you
continually chip away at them get their
arm or get their weapons you get weapons
to hunt them with but in this they're
actually persistent bosses so I beat the
assassin here and this was early on my
play time I was also trying to make the
gameplay look good so I made a few dumb
decisions which you might see I don't
that's amazing I screwed up the assassin
later on I messed her up I gave her a
wallop here's my Templar there's a few
new units we'll get into that but you
see the assassin talking you up she
remembers your action she starts to
learn from you if we wait you have a man
there's a ton to talk about in the
strategy layer of the game for the the
XCOM layperson there's a strategy layer
where you're building a base and
researching technologies and recruiting
troops and just doing all the
big-picture stuff and then this is the
actual tactical turn-based combat right
here where you bring your units and at
this point I have a six person squad
including the robot three of the new
units a specialist medic and a ranger
but standard yeah and the chosen the
longer you wait to do the covert
missions which are also take place in a
strategy layer to find their strongholds
the stronger they'll get so you can go
in earlier with a weaker squad with less
powerful weapons less powerful armor not
as many abilities that can kind of get
you out of a tight spot and you could go
in and try to fight them when they're
also weaker or you could wait until your
team is just dope as [ __ ] like mine is I
don't know that I necessarily avoided
swearing there when I try to channeled
Michael huh yeah so I should I should
have gone into overdrive
right here with my I was fine yeah you
should have people called it out in the
YouTube comments
yeah you were all 20 people yeah why not
I so give you [ __ ] so those so that's
actually it takes Jake Solomon the
creative director we had him on the
lobby stage actually at e3 and he was
saying they took they love what shadow
of Mordor did and they loved a shadow
war seems to be doing and they wanted to
take that persistent boss kind of
Nemesis system where they learn from
your your actions and your habits and
they make they're harder to fight later
on and they remember it they'll say like
oh remember I killed she killed one of
my favorite soldiers and she mentioned
it later that got me but anyway though
those the chosen the three big boss did
you kill them you get their weapons much
like you might expect three new units
this is the Reaper that I just moved the
stealth kind of glass cannon they can
stay they have a chance to stay in
stealth when they shoot there's the
Templar which is the psionic one with
kind of the psylocke blades and if
you're an excellent fan and then there's
the skirmisher which is kind of just a
battle tank which can do a lot of stuff
but there are some bigger aspects which
you kind of can see in this gameplay
were watching did you just throw a
grenade there was a flashbang it
disorients them and she's in the ship or
he or she it was a flashbang yes she
wasn't the ship and I was trying to
disorient her so she would have a harder
time attacking my and I also if you know
XCOM you'll notice that she is not
triggering overwatch when she runs up to
people so you go to overwatch right
there and that essentially means if an
enemy moves in their line of sight even
if it's not your turn you're gonna fire
at them but she ignores overwatch as you
can see which makes it tough to fight
her because she's more of a gorilla kind
of getting it out kind of person but
they're also soldier bonds happening
here and the strategy layer you have
these soldiers developed bonds and they
can get and make out on the battlefield
yes they can give each other extra
actions they can give each other a nice
kiss on the cheek before they go into a
firefight you serious know they don't
like heal each other they can revive
each other easier you can give each
other an extra action you can do it
later on when they get to a certain bond
level you can do a dual strike where
they both attack someone is one attack
which is huge and that's awesome and you
see I'm fighting the loss here these
zombies I'm ranting there's just a lot
to talk about this game it's a broad
strokes it changes XCOM to in several
different ways I was kind of annoyed by
the loss the zombies at first but then
you start to realize how to avoid
fighting them and I got all you start
man
your resistance relationships and that's
kind of like city-states if you play
civilization games a lot you're managing
kind of your your rapport with these
factions and that factors into abilities
you're unlocking and soldiers you're
unlocking and different missions you get
there so man do to be upfront we're not
supposed to be talking about like our
full-on opinion yet cuz the review will
be up on the 24th I don't have anyone to
review this yet it'll be up on the 24th
that's the embargo so at least I can
talk about on the 24th right now this is
all just preview man is this worth
pulling up my save and doing like Iron
Man Run or something um you can't know
you'd have to start new game out imagine
how so that that's my questions I never
played XCOM - would it should I get the
suggestion and is it too much cuz
usually adds a lot like what I feel
overwhelmed with like mechanics so do
they explain it all in a way where a new
player would feel okay yes they explain
it
there's a couple so XCOM like when they
introduce new things you go on this
mission they'll kind of explain a new
mechanic but not too overtly they'll let
you figure out how to use it but the
paté overall pacing of XCOM 2 is like 10
times better now there's no there's
usually a couple hours at the beginning
if you played a bunch of campaigns where
you're like I'm just gonna research to
this I know that's gonna help me I'm
gonna research this that's gonna help me
and it's kind of like civilization you
go for the stem the same research tree
and whatnot and you do the same missions
and this right away you start getting
connected with these resistance factions
and it helps the pacing because the
expansion also revamped how a lot of old
mission types worked so if you were
doing a retaliation mission for instance
to stop their dark project progressing
you would go in and have to rescue a
bunch of civilians while also killing
the aliens and this one there's actual
resistance members that kind of fight
with you and you're actually saving them
one squad at a time there's just more
layers to each of the mission types and
they also added a few new mission types
such as a ambushes you can get ambushed
when you're on a covert action so
instead of fighting you'll actually just
literally try to sprint away I haven't I
didn't fire a shot the whole time last
time I got ambushed this is a soldier
bond right here he just revived him yeah
put his hand on his head man yes if you
have played XCOM - now's the time get in
it's the same day as Mario plus Rabbids
but the expansion not it doesn't just
add things like new units and new
research options and new weapons
missions it makes the pacing of the game
I think from my time with it now that 60
hours I put into it it makes the time
like that much better that was all
really good but it wasn't the format we
agreed upon as a longtime XCOM player
does not have was supposed to work but
yeah I know watch it back we'll figure
it out no any other questions do you
know if they're selling it how much does
it cost you know much across 40 I
believe they just announced today
they're pushing the ps4 Xbox one
versions back to September 12th because
of performance issues they're gonna make
sure that it works I guess I'm wondering
like if I since I don't own XCOM - like
could I buy it like oh yeah yeah so with
enemy within it would probably just be
$60 I imagine if you're getting the
hoard the whole thing that's pretty good
let me double check that actually how
long is it supposed to take her this is
pretty big right yeah so you necks calm
yeah beating one campaign can take
anywhere from like 25 hours to like 50
but half the fun of this game is just
starting over sometimes and failing I
didn't this is the first campaign since
I reviewed the game that I haven't
played on Iron Man which means you can't
you can just reload saves and whatnot
but it is reinventing that the game very
broadly but all yeah very thoroughly but
also like on like I'm minut scale as
well I'm looking up the price trying to
find a quick cuz I actually don't know
we got fortunately sent to code by 2k to
play it when are you guys gonna play
this game
$40 I've tried to play XCOM and it I
just don't like it no I don't think it's
bad at all I just don't like it yeah I
think you guys play it I'd like to yeah
Mario and rabbits comes out the same day
though it's every like it's everything
I've like loved about modern video games
it's this emergent characterization when
I lose it are we gonna dive into why you
like I come to you right now that's a
huge waste of time no no okay
with were the chosen
this expansion it makes it even more
what I love about modern games this
emergent characterization when you lose
someone like this it's just even that
more painful now you have these super
powered units and these three new
factions and it's even more painful
losing I lost one of my skirmishers and
it felt like I lost the entire squad
damn
the Nemesis kind of inspired system
makes the campaign mean a lot more and
it's personal you kind of have beef with
some of these guys and some of the that
assassin girl and it's it's it can be
frustrating but the payoff is anyway but
I can tell you first game to actually
like use the Nemesis system outside of
shadow matter inside of chef mortar
because I remember like when that came
out everyone's like oh just wait guys a
couple years everyone's gonna steal from
this and like no one did I mean like to
go farther back in it than shadow more
tower far cry 2 did that with your
allies of vanilla version of it you kind
of had those allies that started coming
in to save you sometimes you build right
yeah look - hello neighbor it's gonna
yeah it's slightly different but it's
the same principle
that's a sure managed basis right yeah
then state of decay did it with your
allies as well but no nemesis I don't
think so and then it's surprising like
in 2014 that's everybody's like this is
the next big thing and that's what a
bunch of developers we did a bunch of
like behind the scenes kind of feature
documentary recently with you know
people who started immersive Sims like
Warren Spector Richard Garriott and the
people who are still making them ref :
Tonio just left arcane but when they
were working on prey we talked to them
and they were saying that was one thing
they constantly looked to was shadow of
mordor and i am also surprised that more
the chosen seeds have the first thing
touching on it look at Nemesis style
system in a game like pray yeah it would
actually be like really cool it would
make sense it would make it even more of
an immersive sim so I don't know
hopefully more people do catch on a
couple of weeks reboot is literally
gonna be about more games and I don't
not anymore I mean you pretty much did a
reboot episode right now on ex-con yeah
oh yeah pretty much did a review I don't
know you should go check this out when
it comes out well maybe we'll have our
full view up an embargo on the 24th best
and read it yeah ooh
challenge cool ex-con to where the
chosen best game ever made
here we go observer cyberpunk Blade
Runner fans here oh yeah oh yeah
what Blade Runner have you seen it piece
Blade Runner yes Luke Skywalker observer
came out from Bluebird studio which is
delightful to say yeah we checked out
this morning but Rob you played until
2:00 yesterday Pete after you saw we had
a pretty glowing freelancer you come in
2 a.m.
clarify 2 a.m. that's how late he stayed
up yeah yes yes this is a game that was
sort of coming and I saw and I was like
this looks very interesting but I didn't
actually realize it was done by the
people who made layers of fear that kind
of would have changed my anticipation a
bit and then we got the text in from the
freelancer and I was like hmm
this sounds like something pretty crazy
so I had to sit down and play it and
it's got some problems but it's by and
large a very immersive cyberpunk
detective story that isn't necessarily
too ambitious but it's pretty good at
the things that it does hmm
it's got some fluff that I don't
necessarily love but really just the
atmosphere and the tone that it delivers
and conveys is super strong and
successful yeah we kind of I was asking
you how the gameplay actually functions
like is it a walking sim is it kind of
just the scenario part that yeah I mean
you're basically you spend a lot of your
time investigating this apartment
building in the slums of a dystopia
where people have accepted you know
technology into their life wholesale
because of that some things have gone
wrong like they've lost their humanity
for existence but anyone with augments
is also pretty much fallen victim to I
think it's like neo phage or something
like that like right basically a
sickness that infects people with
augmentations like oh this is your
punishment for losing your community I
believe it's one like like nanites go
like out of whack like sure and it's and
there's I think for the most part like
all or most people in the world are in
this and this time have augments whereas
like it's pretty common you know like
they've said it as far as like in the
future like people are expecting like
you know we're already making hearts
right like everyone can just like go
into the garage like a car shop and just
like get a new muffler or like whatever
it is
and that's kind of the case for so many
people so it's super mysterious like
everyone is just everyone just seems
freakin out of their just weird just
weird I mean it's like you know the
effect of what's been going on like has
taken a toll on like psychosis and like
just like people in general like I yeah
you don't you don't get like a lot of
really in-depth examination of
characters but that's kind of one of the
game's strengths is how much it can
convey through very minimal interaction
so this guy you run into him a few times
and he's kind of like slow and you feel
like dim-witted I think it's like the
second scene when you interact with him
he sort of discusses why he has the
augments he has like why he is the way
he is and it's because I believe he was
like caught in like a war zone and had
to do some stuff so it's like yeah he's
kind of a weirdo and at first you're
like screw this guy but then you're like
help me and I feel bad for you yeah this
is the this is what you're left with but
so when you're not walking around you're
doing a lot of this you're examining
items trying to find evidence to you
know deduce clues and solve there's one
big crime you're trying to solve but you
sort of solve little steps along the way
and so when you're not looking through
apartment buildings it's stuff like that
you are talking to people in the
apartments but through these sort of
like video terminals at their door right
and all you're really given it's sort of
like a peephole and that you don't see
their face you see like their eye and
it's it's really like glitchy kind of
image everyone's eye looks different or
it's like a different part of their face
or like sometimes they'll like looks
like they'll cover it up but sure there
but that's a favor I ask you a question
do you have any Binaca and so yeah I
mean the immersion of this game is what
made me play for four hours straight and
I wanted to keep going Peter now so what
you're seeing here too is that you have
as you are investigating you have kind
of like two different types of you know
discovery of items yeah so there's like
an electromagnetic pulse and then
there's your your like bio right and
that's how you find different clues and
you don't you pick up objects rotate
them get like you know bits of clues
obviously that you remember or like a
lot of times I wanted to like pull on a
notebook and like remember certain
things yeah but one of the most
interesting things that it's funny
because we were
kind of talking about Tacoma just not
too long ago about that like
satisfaction because that is very much
again like an investigative type of game
like here the idea of like you can pick
up an object and like put it back when I
close a cabinet again
I feel like this here was like one of
the best VR games it wasn't VR for me in
how you open up different like drawers
and cabinets is right I hold down the
trigger kinetic yeah and then you and
then yeah then you're using this the
stick or your house if you're playing a
PC I guess your house yeah it's your
hand forward as though you're opening
the door right anything is so fluid in
like just that alone
like it's like very VR like I can't even
imagine what this game would be like in
Fury be really surreal but that alone
and I would hope that is something they
would consider it on the road but that
alone really helped that immersion of
just like I just was obsessed and you
know you again like the environments are
gorgeous every room you walk into ever
any corner in the room and like look
around and it's just a crazy looking
spectacle but I get but it gets far
crazier so yeah one of the deals so that
we should say the main character is
voiced and provided by Rooker how're ya
obliviously and his we can get to his
performance in a minute but one of the
things his character can do is read
people's memories and this can be
someone who was alive still or not alive
as it were and he does this by sort of
like jacking into you know he takes his
cable like I have his wrists and Jack's
it into their neck and when you're
examining memories I mean none of us
have memories that are perfect that have
every detail that have all this stuff
laid out in sequence as it should be our
memories are fractured and broken and
distorted in some ways and that's really
what you experience when you get into
these memories
this isn't footage of it here I I'm I
didn't put it I cut all all this stuff
we don't have footage of that ready for
this I was gonna hold off because I feel
like that's kind of spoilery
okay well it's cool though go to the
review because on the review page I had
a clip that we did okay I mean I'm like
because this was a game where like as I
was like assembling just a real quick
rushed gameplay highlight I like really
wanted to avoid stuff because having it
like happen was man like yeah those
jackings to people's minds are like
right the set pieces as you yeah so
these memories that I described is
broken and fractured and weird as you're
exploring them the experience is very
surreal I mean the game is already a bit
spooky it takes on very much a horror
vibe look at this room you start to you
start to lose sense of space and self in
these memory sequences and it's trying
to tell a story both of I have beaten
the gaming I miss telling the story of
the character you're jacked into but I
think even part of Rutger Hauer is
character yet seeps in a little bit so
it's just really interesting like yeah
there's always this tug of war between
the abilities you have and the job it
affords you and the access it affords
you to information but then how that
also has a negative impact on yourself
and the job you're trying to perform
it's super interesting in that regard
but yeah it's like if there are any
faults I'd say Rutger Hauer there's a
pretty sleepy performance I liked it
yeah I liked it too another viewer but I
liked it in that it felt very like trope
like like in that like I'm just like
almost like over exaggerated as far as
like rass penis yeah and just like not
super exaggerated or emotional right
like very like right like I enjoy
listening to it but so but like one of
the early scenes and this is not a
spoiler when the early scenes is he gets
like a call from like a long relative
that he thought a very important
relative to him that he thought was gone
he hadn't heard from in a while and his
reaction is just like oh it's you
Oh like if I if I had a loved one that
was missing for a decade and they've
reached out to me you'd be like oh my
god like you know what I mean there'd be
some emotion behind it he is just that
constant well stagnation am I missing
something whoa I mean this isn't a thing
a spoiler in the beginning of the of the
game you know you notice that he has a
straight robotic arm yeah this is his
hits like psychosis I think plays into a
lot of the themes of this game where
it's like
well but what point who at what point is
is are these people humans yes and like
when like time like I don't know I don't
know there's so many characters that
like we're like you'll see like I feel
like outbursts of like a cry for help or
something like that it's like super
interesting like there are some
characters like it seems really boring
to knock on these doors and get like
four images of like an eye just like
flashing your face but the writing I
think of these the residents and again
you don't really interact with them like
visually like you just hear them I feel
like there were moments in this game
were like I walked I was like damn that
was only maybe a minute long but like it
took me like there's rich it was rich
and it like really impacted me I was
like that the voice acting in those is
really great good which is what it which
is why I think I don't like Rick or how
her so much and maybe why I don't buy
the theory that it's a conscious
decision on his part he sounds like a
tired actor to me yeah so I don't know
you have to play for yourself if it fits
the tone and in many scenes but there
are some where I'm left thinking like
really right like that's that's how
you're gonna play this out the thing
you're saying about the fractured
memories kind of is what entices me I'm
sold on it right now I played I won't
only play that half an hour but I kind
of get what they're going for aside from
I haven't seen much of like the horror
angle yet yeah I'm curious to see if
they expound upon that shattered memory
and maybe kind of use that to maybe make
it an accidental unreliable narrator in
a way like nobody's reliable measure
their memories I haven't finished it I
think we're around the same probably
halfway I'd say there's about an eight
maybe nine hour game if you really like
I've heard very yeah four to five twelve
you have like you know you open up you
to your you're more like your detective
screen and you have like sub quests
basically along with like you can you
can kind of like a you know they're all
pretty pretty simple it's just a matter
of being thorough right yeah
but going back to like yeah like I think
you're on point like like who Krueger is
as a character what sir you're Lazar ski
thank you
let's are who you are and what your
interpreting is like James that's that's
what I would say like about how it was
like you just you know and that's I feel
like that's apparent in the beginning as
well but as far as like the horror stuff
I'm one like
like PT I got a lot of vibes from PT
yeah like oh very similar yeah in a very
great way where it was just like an
environment and you know mood swings of
like you know I feel uneasy the idea of
walking through PT and seeing different
variations of that one scene that's not
really what you do in this game but it
has that same effect because these
memories they jump around very quickly
and so one minute you're in a room and
the next you're staring down like vast
black space with the most dimly lit path
and some fog and it yet evokes that
sense of like this looks so benign but I
know there's something horrible right
it's like lurking here people compared
at the soma as well I haven't played so
much so I haven't liked something about
it but I looked at footage and I've seen
footage of it and I would say it's very
similar to that as far as like it is a
walking symbol it's again so immersive
we're like I don't know there's
something about like I I know I'm not
gonna get killed like in the and the as
much as I played like there is no moment
and I guess what we talked about the
cat-and-mouse aspect I was kind of
excited I've gotten to that yet I feel
like in that like I'm never like
consistently Hatton Mouse aspect yeah
like no just being like hunted by
something I assume I haven't played it
myself like Resident Evil the last was
very much like luma okay yeah yeah
that's what I saw - he's like you're
constantly hiding away like you're never
you never like like so uneasy I feel
like that's why I could play for so long
yeah a lot like I feel like the audience
I mean unless you're obsessed with
horror games you could play those games
for long periods of times but there's
something about like the exhaustion you
get with like jump scares and such yeah
this is more just disturbing it's just
disturbing
yeah good disturbing but you're never
like super I mean there are some moments
that are really scary but you're never
like super unease - like I can't
continue this anymore no no yeah but
yeah I have to still found myself like
closing doors behind me like like you
know there's the audio work and oh you
gotta play with headphones by the way
like the inter sent the visuals alone
like just yeah like the lighting and
like all the it's one of the random
things I want to bring up that's kind of
touching on the last few things you
mentioned is in those memories there's
like mazes you have to go through
and you have to find the right path but
if you fail the rooms like seamlessly
become the beginning of the path again
mm-hmm and do you remember that remember
how you got through it it takes like
really interesting environmental
awareness and it opens up this like sort
of meta puzzle thing on top of the maze
that you're in which is pretty neat it's
hard to describe if you want to I mean
if you're fan of cyberpunk I think
people are like saying it uses the
cyberpunk kind of Blade Runner ish
aspects well in terms of like the
questions it raises in that character
algae replaces humanity how do we deal
with that yeah and but anyway we our
review is up yes and we're doing to do a
video review because well people are
very interested in this game yeah kind
of this year is full of games that kind
of came out of nowhere and surprised a
lot of people and that's what this is
one of them like night in the woods
along like the narrative track kind of
comes to mind as well we're hoping for
it with rhyme but I don't think it
really hit the mark but anyway you can
go see more about observer
we'll have our video review up soon ish
maybe tomorrow we're gonna aim for oh I
will say I'm good to touch on that much
but I played on ps4 you play it on PC I
had initially a real bad time real bad
time with like the sensitivity of like
the controller we're like at it's like
default setting like you know you're
zipping around like there's not much of
like a nice acceleration factor so it
was if you're gonna play ps4 turn all
turn the sensitivity all the way down
and it's bearable but there were like
pretty significant framerate drops yeah
you saw that in the footage when they
walked into a room it was kind of
stutter II I wouldn't say it's a
deal-breaker for ps4 but like it was
pretty jarring sometimes I don't know if
you had similar experience with PC no PC
ran did yeah we could talk about sonic
mania let's talk about sonic media sonic
it's the second game they got a 9 out of
10 this week mine's rare it was the
first observer Oh check that out
sonic mania I've never I said this a
beginning strive ever beating a Sonic
game before I never bound past like two
zones of a Sonic game
this one's supposedly good you were
playing on your switch today I was
trying to repair of this Joe because I
haven't had as much time to play they're
pretty like slow-paced games right
that's if you're not good old sonic
maybe isn't the easiest to go back to
you're like it's got some really great
charms to it and there are moments when
it's fast but what Sonic mania does
really well is it takes sort of that old
formula and opens it up in in a more
creative and speedy way I think yeah
there's there's more surprises moment to
moment and especially if you're very
familiar with the old Sonic games the
way that it sort of slips in these
little added flourishes is really
rewarding just little animations here
they're like just even that alone yeah
oh goodness
oh yeah the batteries cause Ben was
saying how that gave him that same
feeling said he was playing it on his
switch and it reminded him of how he his
first Sonic game was on again oh really
yeah most of my Sega games when I was
younger on Game Gear feel like you're
gonna be mad at that for some reason why
I don't know because it's an old
platform you're gonna test nice little
fight what are you talking no no I feel
like you're gonna say well the genesis
was just a lot of Genesis games on the
gamegear that I could have been playing
on the Genesis instead your Genesis kid
that's why I'm saying that yes
yeah but y'all know you you know a lot
about Sonic after recent yeah I'm not
sure I'm the expert now 50 minutes of
you did intensive so Pete can I started
touching on it what does it do to evolve
games or does is it good because it goes
back to its roots well yeah I agree that
the older games don't necessarily
especially like the first one doesn't
hold it as well like the everyone thinks
like green hill zone from that original
Sonic but the second you get to like the
second stage it instantly starts slowing
down and just has all these barriers
that where the game wants to go fast and
it prevents you from going fast because
like you have to do really slow ass
platforming or you have two enemies just
start coming out of nowhere and hitting
you they're just no the layouts
extremely well yes it's funny a lot of
Sonic fans will say like their argument
for why those old games are good is like
well no you got to play it like 10 times
and you got to like know the layout
perfectly and then it's fun and like
like that's that's a weak argument right
but I think like by Sonic 3 they started
to kind of figure out like we need to
have every area kind of have these
complexity right yeah like a plan B
faster lanes multiple options you know
like something that sonic sonic has like
more of a leeway with it then Mario
where the the ring system because you
can get hit it kind of kind of knows
that sometimes it can be like a little
[ __ ] so it'll it gives you that
leeway and then when you do get hit or
you fall off like in a pit or something
you don't die you just go to an
alternate lane that's maybe not as fun
way as fun or doesn't have you know
looking an extra like one up or
something right now like that you could
get like there's a reason they
definitely reward you for being able to
get to those like you know more complex
lanes and stuff like that and I think
yeah I think this game just like really
understands that and nails that idea
there was one area there's one zone I
got stuck on because of the boss
and so I nipped doing that zone like
multiple times but I started just like
trying alternate paths and I was shocked
like how many times I kept doing seeing
areas that I had never been in before
like I yeah it's it's fun to go look at
old Sonic games where people will like
take the zone layout and like zoom it
out you can see the paths I really want
to see what they look like for this one
it's like really massive like there were
there are times where I was like oh I'm
I have not redone a second part of this
you know act once you know it's pretty
it's pretty great this was a game that I
I think the first switch game I would
say I'm playing on that that I really
wanted a d-pad I felt like this I
actually don't mind the the analog stick
I kept no no not the analog stick
there's a d-pad but it's not the
traditional all you have with a d-pad
like I don't know like at the rate of
which you know the speed you're going
like I feel like I was taking a wild I
know it wasn't comfortable for me okay
studio op ELISA
nice game what is it what does that mean
studio I stood you waffles it's a it's a
TV studio it's a station so they've like
cool like it's very much feels like a
game aesthetically that's like trying to
be the 90s where it's like yeah you have
a yeah like a TV studio there's a
newspaper printing press that you're
like running through yeah you know it
but what's cool about it is that they're
clearly doing stuff that couldn't have
been done on the original genesis
hardware like it's trying to emulate
that aesthetic but it's like okay these
levels there's no way these levels to be
able to be as big as it could have been
on the genesis there they couldn't have
had this many frames of animation you
know because of like the memory limit it
couldn't have possibly had like there's
more color in this like they're waiting
that style but they're taking advantage
of the current hardware yeah but we're
good but still working within I think
you know like there's the idea of like
how we remember these old games versus
how they actually were right it's like
this suits how we remember those games
even if they actually never were this
way right right
it was colored glasses or I mean it's so
like big things that I think just
instantly make this game better alone is
the widescreen you know like it's like a
huge thing about Sonic is one of the
reasons you kept getting hit by enemies
that you're like well that was [ __ ]
it's because you wouldn't see them in
time because you're you were so limited
and they put sock in the center so you
have like eight frames to maybe like and
see an enemy and then dodge it and the
reaction time is just you know
practically impossible unless you know
ahead of time they're there that's why
people always say like oh you got to
play at 10 times this to have much more
likely way and like being able to
predict and it still like takes some
skill to do sometimes but you're able to
actually do it and they like place
enemies a lot smarter so you're you're
able to do that stuff I've always sucked
at Sonic games maybe this was how I feel
when I was playing a bit like but I I'm
not like afraid of like my inexperience
with like movement stuff like I feel
like I'm ramping up because there's the
drive to like you know go fast like just
hit these like roller coasters it's like
a total pinball feel I love it there's
and again there's just so many little
things like moment-to-moment in every
level or it's like I've never seen that
enemy before I've never seen this little
gimmick before cool [ __ ] like yeah is
like even if you're failing you're like
I can't want to see what else his games
gonna do because it's pretty far out
it's um it's apparently also tacked with
a lot of really subtle references to
Sega's past yes we've got a gallery
going live later today which normally I
don't worry too much about our galleries
or care to pimp them but Heidi camp
somewhere were freelancers did a really
good job her knowledge of Sega is pretty
deep there's some things in there that
even Madison Ellie was like what Easter
eggs that are all spoiled one so in the
competition mode there's like an
announcer the announcers voice is the
guy who did the famous Daytona USA song
whoa see yeah it means you might not
yeah you might have noticed that there's
also like a blimp at one point that goes
by this has like SS Hornet the Hornet is
the name of the car from Daytona USA so
maybe there is some deep Daytona USA
lore that is that is invading Sonic and
taking root but there's one coming out
soon there I think they are doing
Daytona some they at an arcade X where
they showed off a new Daytona
oh so you're sort of but there's a lot
of stuff even too obscure like a Sonic
the Hedgehog popcorn machine I think all
right period in Japan I remember that
one that's like Club Sega in the
background and a lot of things from
Sonic games that were in magazines that
weren't actually in the final versions
of Sonic 1 through 3 are in this game as
well which is pretty cool for fans who
are like that thing that legendary thing
that never happened oh it's this feels
like this only could happen because this
was made by fans yes absolutely the
people who have made their own fan games
and Kristian Whitehead who is a guy's
studio I don't really know him or the
studio but he's been involved in a lot
of ports of old games so it's his
know-how plus the the obvious knowledge
and passion from the fans yeah he
reported the Sonic CD on mobile alright
then that version is also on Steam and
it's like definitely like the version of
play it runs on his own custom engine
that he built which I think is maybe the
same engine they're using for this so it
gets widescreen run so like 60 frames a
second then they also did 1 & 2 as well
although those versions are not on
steam you can only play them on mobile
which kind of sucks they're not in that
like weird Genesis oh no those are the
original emulated oh yeah yeah but that
that's a bummer because a lot of fans
consider those to be like the best
versions of those games because like you
know they run out of solid 60 frames a
second where you know you play that
emulated Genesis wand it's still
emulating Genesis hardware so you get
those weird hiccups you know just by
trying to emulate you know that stuff
that these these ones don't have and
just feels like a much smoother
experience now it's really good so you
won't ride loser there's co-op in this
right it's like a competitive mode but
you can also play like the other person
can control tails for example even if
tails doesn't really make a huge
meaningful difference and the grand
scheme of a game but yes yeah he saved
my ass a few times through the [ __ ] oh
yeah oh I'm on a chemical factory
chemical plant that they made chemicals
that chemical is tough oh yes infamous
it's tough stuff yeah I haven't figured
it out yet
this was after my 2:00 a.m. binge of
nightcap huh didn't wait you just did
that with another recent game didn't use
some fast pace crazy game what was it
now let me just press in a while or
something you probably tried to like
master mode or something shut your mouth
oh yeah you're right it was master mode
to trial the sword yeah that's what it
was
man I don't I don't think I'll ever beat
that on master mode it is mine box one
stop you trying so yeah we all agree
they've they've made sonic good not just
for a nostalgic sake but for modern
palates yeah I have a question do you
feel like the because I would say it's
like half and half half new stages half
old stages do you feel like if they make
another one like they need to just be
all new yeah yeah cuz yeah I love these
like the remixes are really well done
and they introducing new mechanics that
are great but it feels like that was
kind of their way of like trying to like
get people into this is the transition
of music transition but unlike other
games that I've seen do that we're you
know very much like oh the old stages
were the good ones cuz you're just
remixing old good stuff and the new
stages are kind of whatever I think the
new stages are just as good if not
better so I mean I think we want it I
want them to do new stuff I wouldn't be
surprised if Sega you know involving
these new developers for a new Sonic
game was like look you have to do
something that is classic right but now
with the success this has I can imagine
that they're gonna be limited you know
do whatever you want yeah like yeah okay
you guys did it car plush go for it
other question let's talk about this
with Matt where how do you feel like the
sonic team feels about this the sonic
team is had to have changed so much
since the 90s I can't imagine there's
still the same people at the helm not
all the way the guy made Sonic Adventure
is still in there somewhere but just
like you have this team of people who've
been like trying to like reinvent Sonic
like they've literally been saying like
we're bringing Sonic back to his roots
since Sonic oh six mm-hmm and like you
know hipster misses a lot of people like
generations but I didn't feel like Sonic
is still kind of been that joke for
years and now everyone's like man like
Sonic is finally back and it's by the
people who have not involved in any of
those games like it took a whole new
team like I'd feel like a little burned
I think is maybe on that original like
Sonic team to some degree right it
depends with the original Sonic team
they get George Lucas well yeah it
depends like if they wanted to make
those games that we don't deem good or
if they were told to make those games
yeah vindication like see I told you
[ __ ] execs yeah this is the sonic
this is ready so who knows it's hard to
say it's cathartic for them maybe maybe
yeah they're like can we help with them
with that now great yeah make Bernie
Rangers too so sonic mania a very great
game superb you might say it's not much
GameSpy you can go watch that you read
it mess Pinelli here did a great review
of it you can go check it out more play
it on platforms hit me switch xbox one
ps3 con pc sorry wait on pc yeah yeah
wait up
I think it's which is the version of
play there's some weird issues with like
some people's system like getting the
home button you hit the home button and
it like takes a couple seconds or like
to get out of the game yeah it's really
weird but there's actually a you leaving
playing it like bronze at 60 frames like
I don't know it's great and it looks so
good on that screen yeah it's wonderful
oh and it's like the levels are so fast
to like it makes it's the kind of thing
where I just picked up and like I'll
just play like a dog pooping cool sonic
mania a good segue that's pretty much a
show but giveaway is actually sonic
mania as well collector's edition a
couple of weird rules here the ps4 is UK
only the Xbox one is us only so if
you're in either of those spots and want
this 12 this really cool-looking statue
of Sonic and that Genesis is a hair
bigger than a standard Genesis 2 so if
that's your barometer it's bigger than
that that's cool second cross recast
with golden ring metallic collector's
card with download key 12-inch statue
with Sega start up audio and the deluxe
box is pretty cool too like this box I
was like emulating old Genesis boxes I
wish they actually came with an actual
box I know
yeah and they apparently like gave out
like a manual at e3 to like people that
like came by the beer and something like
that so there's like a manual out there
the cartridge will fit in a Genesis
cartridge box
I saw someone put it on a Sonic and
Knuckles so it'll fit it'll fit on that
it'll it'll fit on the 32x
it will not fit in a standard Genesis
just alone not really but you can like
finagle it obviously doesn't do anything
yeah yeah yeah but yeah it's like we're
this close to having an actual box and a
manual and we have a cartridge so well I
want like only a limited run tip you
know companies that do stuff like that
like I'm a bit or something there are
people who've uploaded you know PSD
files you can print out but not my own
yeah but you want to buy it from a
company so you know it's official right
yeah right cool consumerism
if you don't follow James Bond Twitter
go do that and retweet that giveaway
tweet from Chiva she'll be up puttin up
on Twitter she might be in the twitch
chat right now maybe not but go follow
us retweet that pick you later on the
week again the ps4 is UK only Xbox one
is us only and
thanks Eva for setting that up and we'll
pick random winners later in a week
that's our show
I'm off for two weeks someone else has
got a host we don't really know who it's
definitely gonna be yet not me but uh
maybe me yeah I'm gonna go work from our
East Coast office and go on vacation for
a week I don't know where I'm gonna go
on a vacation we'll figure that out
whoa no I just can't even win takes yeah
no I'll be in New York for like two
weeks I'd be hanging out playing XCOM
just get like a staff for like a you
know picnic yeah is it a hobo bindle
people have been freaking out about you
almost knocking your glasses off the
desk all show.we back when I was down to
me hardware stuff we were gonna do a
show about hardware deals and it was
gonna be called hard times Peter Brown
and it was gonna be me with a hobo
bindle with like graphics cards sticking
out of it I might be insensitive heyday
Brown well it wouldn't be hard times as
always I would just you know like
pockets with like USB cables just
flowing out of them just where Oh what's
this isn't funny
yeah anyways you'll probably be playing
you gonna be playing I mean I don't know
I'm wrapping up your kazoo right now
that review about early next week kiwami
that is the follow-up although it's a
remake of the original as to follow-up
to zero the recent prequel other than
that problem or sonic probably finished
observer you like that's gonna be in the
geek nut I don't know we're gonna be
talking about it later in the year I
think that's very subtle shut up Rob
would he play observer Rutger Hauer
whisper yeah I won't play more that
definitely sonic mania way uncharted
lost legacy oh yeah yeah that review
going up next week as soon as tomorrow
that goes up tomorrow if you're
interested in on try to loss legacy
Michela concepción will have something
up to read for you I think watch I think
tomorrow morning we're playing drive
we're doing 2 Triforce
Triforce slash Zelda master mode I was
gonna watch you play and I was gonna be
funny cool all right
John Luke Ivan played observe yet but I
definitely want you yeah ever you liked
it everything about that just seems like
that is
absolutely my jam yeah yeah immersive
Sims you guys are like huge fans prey
and all that jazz it's it's definitely
that it's good my love to yes and then I
need to play hell-blade you do you all
do it's what do you think like observer
and hell-blade like I would say are like
are in that same boat of like gotta wear
headphones because it's be alone like I
don't even know if I can play observer
in this office like and be prepared for
like whispers in your ear and and just
like crazy ambience yeah if you can get
yourself into a fragile state by like
not eating for 48 hours do that - all
right as always
wait I normally thank you in the back
but thank you for coming on today
hitting the desk Oh getting on that
sweet wood can I can i pimp my my
history of Uncharted video very well may
not yeah go check it out or pimp it
I'll tell do it I'm history of Uncharted
yeah sonic 1 yeah 50 minutes it's 30
minutes good it's very good it's good
primer for the Lost legacy which takes
place after uncharted 4 so going into in
terms of Naughty Dog development the
games themselves you want to know more
you did a pretty comprehensive research
oriented history of pretty cool video
check it out it's up it went up this
morning so everybody watch that or Sonic
you did it history sonic watch to play
sonic mania - cool that's our show
thank you Richard Lee Thank You Erik Tay
in the back that was a long show 12:26
glad y'all stuck around - on YouTube
twitch GameSpot and as always they'll
see you next week I won't be here I'll
see everybody in September
am I gonna be here next week on the desk
I don't or in the office bring you on oh
you can you could be Callie and you oh
okay yeah we should get a dog let's
bring a dog in here can you host John
Luke we'll see you later
back to your home
guys go or have a good week I'll see you
in a couple weeks and everybody thank
you for joining very much we'll see you
next Wednesday at 11:00 a.m. here in San
Francisco California
I'm Lobby later
[Music]